mitten in westeuropa ist eine neue
fluchtroute entstanden mit dem
schlauchboot von frankreich nach
großbritannien
ich war in deutschland 2.000 menschen
harren in zeltlagern an der
französischen küste aus viele leben seit
jahren in europa zum beispiel ich habe
in deutschland keine chance
doch die überfahrt ist lebensgefährlich
der ärmelkanal ist eine der
meistbefahrenen schifffahrtsstraßen der
welt
[Musik]
cup green
am urlaubsstrand militärpatrouille
seit diesem sommer überwacht die
französische marine den küstenabschnitt
um calais denn täglich starten von hier
flüchtlinge richtung england mit dem
schlauchboot
rund 2000 menschen haben das seit august
geschafft und viele von ihnen sprechen
deutsch erinnerung auf dem handy an
sowas wie heimat
düsseldorf/dortmund barbara aziz hat es
29 nach seiner flucht aus dem irak hat
er in wuppertal als friseur gearbeitet
und später als fensterputzer seine frau
und sein zehnjähriger sohn leben in der
türkei
seit sieben jahren warten sie
[Musik]
ja sagt du bist sieben jahre hast du
mich mein sohn jetzt kennen mich nicht
manchmal sagt du bist mein vater
manchmal zu müssen schreibt
sie arm nicht das abare hat deutschland
verlassen hat asyl bescheid abgelehnt
ich kann nicht mehr das machen
und hat man mit an wahl gesprochen
[Musik]
cover
ein halbes jahr ist das jetzt her
seitdem lebt er hinter diesem gebüsch
alle leute hier geschlafen
wir schlafen hier
dass mein zimmer seit sieben jahre in
deutschland dass mein zimmer scheiße
dass meine handtuch
[Musik]
stärker sechs monaten ist salvador
vielleicht auch kein kaffee
mehr als 2000 flüchtlinge sollen derzeit
am ärmelkanal rund um die französische
hafenstadt calais ausharren
ein offizielles flüchtlingslager gibt es
nicht dafür alle 48 stunden
polizeikontrollen die botschaft bleiben
unerwünscht
jonathan becker ist 20 seit juli
verteilt er mit einer hilfsorganisation
täglich essen wasser und das nötigste
zum leben sehr viele menschen getroffen
die gerade aus deutschland kam und dort
einige monate bis zu vielen jahren
verbracht haben sich versucht haben zu
integrieren ein leben begonnen haben ein
neues
ich habe viele getroffen die als pfleger
und pflegerinnen gearbeitet haben
friseure frisörin waren darunter auch
fensterputzer so besonders jobs die in
deutschland vielleicht nicht ganz so
beliebt sind aber sehr sehr gebraucht
werden zäune und stacheldraht sollen
menschen fernhalten neue lagerplätze
werden regelmäßig geräumt
[Musik]
auf diesem platz vor etwa zwei monaten
noch sehr sehr viele leute gekämpft
nachdem der etwas größere dschungel dort
drüben geräumt wurde
diese wurden dann ebenfalls geräumt und
haben in einem waldstück in der nähe
gelebt vergangene woche hat er hier noch
essen und wasser verteilt der
französische staat bietet kaum hilfe
jonathan becker stellt uns einen mann
vor der fünf jahre in erlangen gelebt
hat auch er spricht deutsch
ganz offen reden will er nicht dann
ergibt sich also meine familie wie es
denn überhaupt das ist meine familie
sind versorgung nicht machen
mit einem gefälschten studentenvisum sei
er von äthiopien nach deutschland
gekommen nach nur drei tagen sei er
kontrolliert worden und die sache
aufgeflogen
nach einigen monaten gefängnis bekommt
er trotzdem eine duldung kann sogar eine
ausbildung machen ist schon eine
ausbildung gehabt
das ist ja das habe ich für eine
gearbeitet im alter haben also eine
rettung wenn eine
gemeinschaftsunterkunft und das problem
mit der gemeinschaftsunterkunft sie sind
ganz weit weg von der gesellschafter
sowie sieht so weit wird isoliert voller
gäste fünf jahre lebte er lang eine
sache wird er nie vergessen es war immer
dieser frage hart ist ich wirklich
gehasst habe michael sauer bist du da
ich bin ein mensch und ja ich bin seit
fünf jahren in deutschland heimatlos den
und ich sag's freunde
es ist schön dass das ist bekommen und
bin also wo ich gearbeitet habe also
sehr betreuung es gab keine kollege die
wieder pausen gemacht habe man keine
mich begrüßt aber und ja ich bin nicht
wirklich gewollt hier
2017 wird sein asylantrag abgelehnt er
fast einen neuen plan england dort habe
er freunde die erzählen die asyl chancen
auf der insel seien besser
muss man also ich bin noch nicht so weit
wo ich sage ich musste es probieren
ein französischer spielplatz und die
kinder sprechen deutsch
[Musik]
das ist drei jahre alt und genau wie die
beiden anderen in deutschland gehören
alle drei besuchten den kindergarten in
hamburg wie heißt du die kurden aus dem
irak haben vier jahre in deutschland
gelebt die männer auf dem bau gearbeitet
die frauen eine sprachschule besuchen
ich habe schon die einst wertete gemacht
und meine tochter gegen kindergarten
immer und dann ich habe ich war sehr gut
lief aber ich weiß nicht warum
warum im juni 2020 der abschiebe
bescheid kommt versteht sie bis heute
nicht
sie zeigt uns videos von dem leben was
sie seit zwei monaten führen
wir schlafen
ein einkaufswagen als wäscheständer
kinderwagen und transportmittel
nachts ist es am schlimmsten am abend
wir können nicht atmen weil diese wie
eine plastik man kann nicht atmen man
kann nicht es tut mir sehr leid wir
gehen hier keine toiletten
das ist eine monate shop einmalige durch
eine monate fünfmal haben sie versucht
den ärmelkanal überqueren kommt bisher
wasser in the woods aber trotzdem was
machen
zwölf stunden seien sie auf dem meer
gewesen england in sichtweite geschafft
haben sie es nicht
diese müssen sich
hast du
ich mache das alles von meiner tochter
ich möchte gebe sie eine kurze lie ein
gutes leben ein paar dixi-klos am
straßenrand und ein öffentlicher
wasserhahn frankreich wählen die
flüchtlinge nicht sagt jonathan becker
auch nicht die die aus deutschland
kommen wo fünf jahren hat angela merkel
gesagt dass wir es schaffen werden und
wir haben es nicht geschafft menschen zu
integrieren einem großen maße wir haben
viele menschen verloren
wir müssen es besser machen in zukunft
und wir sollten es schaffen das weil ich
dass wir es schaffen aber auch der
eritrea john musste deutschland
verlassen wie alle hier träumt er von
einer zweiten neuen zukunft in
großbritannien weil die flucht illegal
ist will er lieber unerkannt bleiben
mein traum zum ersten mal nach england
wenig kriege papier schießen wir erstmal
meine mutter sie zum ersten mal meine
mutter nur zweimal
mitgeschrieben hatte noch heiraten mit
15 als john aus eritrea aufgebrochen mit
20 ist er nach deutschland gekommen fast
fünf jahre später zieht er weiter sein
ziel eine dauerhafte
aufenthaltsgenehmigung mit reisepass in
großbritannien das was er sich von
deutschland erhofft hatte
[Musik]
ich war nicht da beim booten heiligen er
noch ein kinderchor müller
guck mal ich finde ich da hin meine
mutter ist krank sie ist glaubt
gt
wenn das glück oder eine stunde wenn
also klug wenn hast kein glück bleibt
die 23 jahren hier nur ein cover hat ist
mittlerweile seit einem halben jahr hier
zweimal hat er es probiert mit dem
schlauchboot erfolglos 2500 euro kostet
die überfahrt sein geld ist aufgebraucht
was bleibt arbeiten für die schlepper
als fahrer zum beispiel muss autofahren
vor 200 400 euro bewusst 30 leute über
20 leute fahren nachts die wasser mit
schlauchboot nach england der kurdische
friseur aus dem irak der sieben jahre in
wuppertal arbeitete will noch nicht
aufgeben ich hoffe zusammen mit meiner
frau ein laden kaufen arbeite zusammen
und mein sohn auch das aber ich denke
dass alle doch seine hoffnung schwindet
jeden tag
[Musik]